to today's Richard M carp distinguished
lecture I don't think I've ever seen
this Auditorium quite so full before so
I'm Sandy Irani I'm the associate
director of the Simons Institute and for
those of you who are unfamiliar with the
Simons Institute we are the world's
leading international venue for
collaborative research and theoretical
computer science we bring together the
world's leading researchers and
theoretical computer science and related
fields to study the use of algorithmic
thinking in science and engineering as
well as to study the laws of computation
itself
this particular lecture series we
founded to celebrate the role of the
Simon's founding director dick carp in
establishing the field of theoretical
computer science formulating essential
questions and contributing an amazing
array of results
the series features Visionary leaders
and theoretical computer science and is
geared towards a broad scientific
audience
so we're very grateful to the many
contributors to the Richard M carp fund
who have made this series possible
thank you
so today I'm really delighted to welcome
our speaker Jacob Fox so Jacob is a
mathematics professor at Stanford
University where he's been since 2015
before joining Stanford he was on The
Faculty at MIT he received his PhD in
math from Princeton University in 2010
and after attending MIT as an
undergraduate Jacob was awarded the
overwolf hawk prize in 2016 for his
outstanding accomplishments to discrete
mathematics and the clinic prize in 2010
for new findings in Ramsey Theory and
apparently Jacob has been working on
Ramsay Theory a very long time
because in high school in 2002 he
received second place in the Intel
science Talent search for a mathematics
project entitled rainbow Ramsey Theory
rainbow arithmetic progressions and
anti-gramsy results so um I guess you've
been studying this for a long time so
um today's talk is entitled erdish and
Shannon a story of probability
Communications and combinatorics so
please help me in welcoming Jacob
[Applause]
thank you it's an honor to be here to
give the carp lecture
um uh carp gave many beautiful and
fundamental applications of probability
to algorithms and complexity Theory
um from
1970s and uh so this is a I hope A
fitting uh talk
related to that
oh right
um every new theorem I talk about is
based on joint work with David conlon uh
hoi Pham who just finished his PhD at
Stanford and lyanna premium
um
so it's all joint work with them
um and I want to start with a historical
perspective
the idea of using probability and
discrete mathematics uh was very
revolutionary and there were two really
fundamental results in the late 1940s
that initiated this this direction in
combinatorics polyertish use probability
to give a lower bound on Ramsay numbers
by considering random graphs
and uh and introducing information
Theory Claude Shannon showed that a
random code is asymptotically optimal
for error correction and these are our
revolutionary Heroes air Edition Shannon
um and uh since then
um these developments ushered in the use
of probabilistic methods that permeate
modern combinatorics and computer
science
um so uh these ideas of using
probability really seemed incredibly
revolutionary at the time there is some
context for it uh in the first half of
the 20th century
probability was put on axiomatic footing
by uh
homogorov in 1933 and probability
already started to see applications in
some other fields in physics in quantum
mechanics there was the uncertainty
principle where probability came in in
number Theory uh in the mid-1930s
Kramer came up with a model for studying
the prime so the prime numbers is a an
important sequence of integers
and uh
uh we still don't not understand a lot
about the prime numbers and up to end
there's about n divided by natural log
of n prime numbers it's known as a prime
number theorem and um instead of saying
stuff specifically about the primes we
can make a lot of good predictions about
the primes by studying instead a random
sequence of integers
where we include the number n in our
random sequence with probability one
over natural log of n independently of
the other elements in the sequence so we
create this random sequence of integers
and then we study properties of this
random sequence and we make guesses
about the prime numbers that they would
have the same properties as this random
sequence and this is Kramer's model and
it makes a lot of correct
predictions about patterns in the primes
there's uh it's not perfect and and
there are some corrections that need to
be done in particular there's only uh
one prime that's even two there's only
one prime that's a multiple of three
three and but you can Factor these into
the model and get a a model that really
makes some very good predictions about
the prime numbers and some of these
predictions have now been proved many of
them have been experimentally tested
there are other nice results in number
Theory
uh that really use probability starting
from the 30s uh with Tehran who is
studying
um if you take a random number from one
to n how many distinct prime factors
does it have
and then air Edition cats uh
strengthened this result and proved that
um it'll it'll follow up essentially a
normal distribution with mean and
variance natural log of natural log
event
so if you take a random integer and so
we can use probability to study things
uh that are not probabilistic
and there's some pushback at the time
against using ideas from probability
it's quite weird uh to think about these
ideas at least it was it's not anymore
and one of the famous quotes from
physics is uh Albert Einstein that says
God does not play dice
um and uh Hardy uh talking about the
prime numbers said 317 is a prime not
because we think so or because our minds
are shaped in one way rather than
another but because it is so because
mathematical reality is built that way
um and so it took a while for people to
really accept this idea of of
probabilistic uh intuition and and using
it to study things
foreign
now I want to discuss uh Ramsay numbers
where erdish was uh using the
probabilistic method
um and it it falls under an area known
as Ramsay Theory it contains many deep
results in mathematics which show that
every very large structure contains a
large well-organized substructure this
is a photo of Frank Ramsey
um and uh Ramsay's theorem which which
is what Ramsay proved guarantees that
every very large graph so a graph
consists of vertices and edges of edges
being pairs of some of the vertices you
can think of it as uh the graph the
vertices being people and you connect
pairs of them by edges if they're
friends
um and Ramsay's theorem guarantees that
every very large graph contains a large
Clique that's a subset of vertices
where every pair of vertices is
connected by an edge or an independent
set which is a set of vertices where
none of the pairs are connected by edges
so you have this large pattern in every
very large graph
and Ramsay numbers quantify how large do
you need to get that the Ramsay number R
of n is the minimum Big N such that
every graph on Big N vertices contains a
clique or an independent set of size
little n
so it's telling us how large do we need
and as an example
um the five cycle so this is a graph on
five vertices uh they're labeled zero
one two three four uh it has no click or
independent set of size three if you
take any three of the vertices you'll
always have an edge between some pair of
them and uh they'll be a missing Edge
between another pair
and so the Ramsey number of three is
greater than five on the other hand
every six vertex graph has a clique or
independent set of size three and uh
this actually appeared as a question on
the 1953 Putnam exam to show that R of
three is six
so uh this is a classical result in the
area
what about the next Ramsay number
um well here's a graph on 17 vertices
it's a famous uh it falls under a famous
family of graphs known as Paley grass
which we'll say a little bit more about
later
um and it has so it has 17 vertex
vertices and you can check that this
graph has no Clique or independent set
of size four any four vertices you take
from this graph you can find two of them
that are adjacent and two of them that
are not adjacent however any graph an 18
vertices will necessarily have to have
four of them that
um make a click or an independent set
we can try to continue in this way
um what about the fifth Ramsey number or
the sixth Ramsey number
and uh there's a a famous quote of
erdish from 1990 at least that's the
earliest reference I could find of it
it's from the Scientific American
article by Ron Graham and Joel Spencer
on Ramsay Theory
and uh his quote says roughly suppose
aliens invade the Earth and threatened
to obliterate it in a year's time unless
human beings can find them the fifth
Ramsay number
we can Marshal the world's best minds
and fastest computers and within a year
we could probably calculate the value
again this was in 1990 our computers
weren't as good then and um
if the aliens demanded the the sixth
Ramsay number however we would have no
choice but to launch a preemptive attack
the point being that this is just a
hopeless task
um
and what's the current state of affairs
with this uh with these problems the the
fifth Ramsay number is known to be
between 43 and 48 there's been some
small improvements in the 30 plus years
since erdish's quote and the six Regency
numbers between 102 and 161.
and um one of the reasons why this is
hard at least if you think about it from
a Brute Force approach
you tried all graphs on 102 vertices
it's a finite check
um and uh so if you look at all labeled
graphs on 102 vertices there's a 102
choose two pairs and for each pair you
have to decide whether or not it's an
edge just to enumerate all the graphs
that's two to the 102 choose two which
is bigger than two to the five thousand
um and uh so so just a Brute Force
approach has no no hope of uh of the
term the six Ramsay number
okay um
in terms of uh asymptotics for this
problem it's known that Ramsay numbers
grow exponentially in little n and so
the right parameterization for this
problem uh involves uh this notion of a
c Ramsey graph so we have a big graph on
N vertices and it's known to be C it's
called C Ramsey if it has no Clique or
independent set of size C Times log base
2 of n
and uh a classical result of bearish and
sakaresh from the 1930s it proof
involves a nice application of the
pigeonhole principle uh repeatedly used
is that there's no half Ramsay graph
that means that every graph on Big N
vertices does have a clique or an
independent set of size half times log
base 2 of n
um and uh so that's a quantitative form
of Ramsay's theorem and there were some
uh improvements on this over the years
although until recently there was no
constant Factor Improvement and within a
last few months there was this
Breakthrough by four mathematicians
Campos Griffiths Morris and sahasra
Buddha
um where they showed that there is some
Epsilon such that there's no half plus
Epsilon Ramsay graph and so
this is something like
0.50001
so there's been some small improvements
on this what about the other Direction
so there's no half Ramsey graph but
eredus showed that almost all graphs on
N vertices are two Ramsey so once you
multiply the Bound by four almost all
graphs have this property now so
um and this was this uh
very influential application of the
probabilistic method I'll just go over
it quickly it's short
so we want to show that there's a if we
take a random graph on Big N vertices it
will it will very likely not have a
clique or independent set of size little
n where little n is two times log base 2
of big n
so how do we consider a random graph and
then vertices well for every pair of
vertices we'll flip a coin with
probability a half it'll be an edge
probably a half it'll be a knowledge
independently of the other edges
the other pairs and the probability that
a given set of little n vertices is a
clique is 2 to the negative n choose two
it's very small and that's because uh
you have n choose two little uh Pairs
and and they're independent whether or
not they form edges and similarly you
have the same probability that the set
of n vertices will form an independent
set and these are disjoined events
so the probability that it forms a
clique or an independent set is two to
the one minus n choose two
by linearity
of vacation the expected number of
cliques or independent sets of size
little n is just going to be well
there's little there's big n choose
little n subsets of size little n and
each of them comes with this probability
two to the one minus n choose two that
it forms a click or an independent set
and you can check pretty easily that
with this choice of little n
this probability uh this expected number
is little low one and uh the union bound
shows that the probability that the
graph is two Ramses at most this
expected value
um
sorry the probability
that g is not too Ramsey that's what
it's supposed to say there sorry is that
it is little I want so the probability
that is two Ramsay is one minus little
one it's tending to one as as big n
tends to Infinity
so almost all graphs on Big N vertices
are two Ramsey
can we construct one and that has
remained a major open problem in the
area to con explicitly construct the C
Ramsey graph for some constant c
um so you'd like to actually construct
these graphs in their the Dark Matters
of graphs they're everywhere and yet we
don't have an explicit construction of
them
um
another way of thinking about it is
there's this phrase a needle and a
haystack where you're trying to find
some rare event and uh
this is an artist who had a performance
art piece in 2014 in Paris
um where he there's a needle in this
Haystack and he's just searching for the
needle this is searching for hay in a
haystack so you're trying to pick out a
piece of hay from a haystack and every
time you go in and pick out a what you
hope is a piece of hay you've got a
needle and
this is what's happening with these
Ramsay graphs anyways um so uh
but we saw some examples before for the
Ramsay number of three and four and so
one might hope that uh we can get a nice
class of Ramsay graphs from generalizing
them
and uh a famous class of graphs that
have some nice pseudo-random properties
are called Paley graphs you start with a
prime number which is one mod four and
the Paley graph PN has vertex set which
is the elements modulo n and two
distinct vertices are going to be
adjacent if their difference is a
perfect square so it's a quadratic
residue
yes
analogy to what's happening okay
we can grab stock some of the stuff that
we grab are maybe needles but we don't
know
right but the things that we know how to
check they always are needles at this
point yeah
it's a reasonable way to think about it
um right so paragraphs uh might be a
great source of Ramsay brass and people
have wondered about this for a long time
in particular the Haley graph on five
vertices is the five cycle which gave us
a tight lower Bound for Ramsay number of
three and the Paley graph on 17 vertices
gives a tight lower bound on Ramsey
number of four maybe these are great
source for Ramsay graphs
um and uh indeed they may be but we
don't know how to show that yet
um and it's a hard problem in number
Theory uh for some n it's known that
paleographs are not good Ramsey graphs
and Montgomery in the uh about half a
century ago uh showed that if you assume
the general Riemann hypothesis
then there are infinitely many n so that
the paleograph on N vertices has a lot
much larger Clique of size log n Times
log log n
some extra log login factor and
unconditionally Graham and ringrose
later showed that for infantly many and
uh the paleograph
has clicks of size log n Times log log n
so they're not technically Ramsey graphs
but this is not so far away
um and uh what do we know in the other
direction
and this goes back to almost 70 years
due to vinaigrade of
The Click number of the Paley graph is
at most square root of that and uh
recently a couple years ago that was
finally improved by a square root of two
factor for the upper bound so that the
bounds are really far apart
roughly in the login World versus square
root of N and there's been really no
serious improvements in a long time
Beyond these uh these these small small
improvements
um and and it appears to be a hard
problem in number Theory to uh to say
more about Paley graphs in terms of
their Clique number
now Paley graphs are a special case of a
large family of graphs that come from
groups and and these are known as Kaley
graphs
so if you have a group G and a symmetric
subset s that just means if you have an
element in your set you also have its
inverse
the kaligraph G sub s has vertex set G
so the elements of your group are the
vertices of your graph and distinct
vertices X and Y are going to be
adjacent if x y inverse so x divided by
Y is an element of s
and the reason why we picked the the set
to be symmetric is so that the graph is
undirected otherwise we'd have to worry
about directions
um and there's a beautiful conjecture of
Nova alone that there is a constant C
such that every finite group has a Kaley
graph which is C Ramsay or something C
um
and uh this is still open
um in this direction it's very natural
to to wonder what about uniformly random
kiwi grass are they Ramsey so do we when
we take a uniformly random Kaley graph
we take each element and it's inverse to
be in the generating set with
probability a half independently of the
other elements
there's been a good amount of work on
this problem uh Novo alone uh showed
that asymptotically almost surely The
Clique number of a uniform random Kaley
graph on any Group G of order n is that
most a constant times a square of log n
so
um gets in the same in the right
ballpark but not necessarily Ramsey and
uh Ben green and then later uh green and
Morris proved asymptotically almost
surely if n is prime the click number of
a uniform random Kaylee graph on the
cyclic group of order n
is uh uh is two plus little o one times
log base 2 of n just like uh uh for the
Heritage ready random graph that we
discussed earlier
um and uh
uh so one may Wonder maybe uh this is a
great direction to go in
um
but there are some limitations if you
instead of looking at the random Kaylee
graph on a cyclic group you take a
vector space over F2 and take a random
Kaley graph on it the click number is
actually substantially larger and uh so
it's uh log n Times log log n within a
constant factor and the reason for this
is that uh
the vector space over F2 has a lot of
subspaces these are subgroups of the
group and if you take a random subset
you'll likely get all the non-zero
elements of a Subspace and then that
Subspace would form a clique as well as
all of its translates and that Subspace
will be of size on the order of log n
Times log log n and
yeah
it was a random graph we already had
asymptotic surely why do you now do this
and you can't it can be the needed
sorry so uh what's the question so we
already know that you can Define these
examples to just look at random props
right but in checking them we don't know
how to do efficiently yeah and now you
have again some asymptotically almost
surely for this more complicated
construction which probably again would
be very hard to check efficiently yes so
why do we that seems to be like no
progress extensive let's take two by
something else
so uh one thing is that already
primographs have a lot less Randomness
than the um than they are just running
random graphs but we're going to tie it
back into coding Theory later and see
that uh random Kaely graphs are actually
helpful for some problems in coding
Theory
so
right so it's it's someone out of a
reduction
um
yeah it's it's it's it's not uh it
doesn't answer the problems about
explicit construction but
um there are good reasons to study uh
these questions
that has to do with errorless
communication
so the First new result I want to tell
you about is that the click number of a
uniform random clearly graph on any
group of order n is asymptotically
almost surely at most uh some constant
times log n Times log log n so it
doesn't get worse than the vector spaces
over F2
um
and uh this works for all uh uh
groups of order n and the reason why it
works for all groups of order n is it
turns out that this has very little to
do with group Theory so we're going to
turn it into a problem of purely
combinatorial and then it's going to
work in a combinatorial setting so the
group theories really the wrong way to
view in terms of proving things
um and on a loans conjecture we can
prove that for almost all n all a
billion groups of order n have a Kaley
graph which is C Ramsay and the ones
that we can't the the values of n have
many factors of two or many factors of
three
um and uh we'll get into why that comes
up later
um
but uh so we there's some progress on
these problems
um now uh understanding these questions
about cliques uh in
um in random Kaylee graphs uh come to we
naturally come to a question and added
combinatorics
um and studying things that are studied
naturally and out of combatorex uh so
the product set a times a inverse is the
set of elements a b inverse where A and
B are elements of a a here is a subset
of a group
and if the group's a billion we would
write it as with addition but since a
group isn't necessarily a billion we
would write our operation uh
multiplicatively like this
and a subset of our group is going to
form a clique in the Kaylee graph
if and only if uh the non-identity
elements of a a inverse of this product
set is going to be a subset of our
generating set s
so this is uh just translating what it
would mean for the a to be a clique
so uh what this question about uh
understanding
um cliques in random candy grass really
boils down to is
is a question about counting uh subsets
of a of a group of a given order little
n with small doubling or rather
differencing here A A inverse is at most
K times n first where K is allowed to
range so a a inverse fa is a kind of a
arbitrary set it could be all all the
way up to quadratic and n but if a is a
subgroup then it would be just the size
of a which would be n so it's somewhere
between n and n squared and you'd like a
bound uh that uh is small if K is small
and this looks like a really weird bound
here C is an absolute constant and
there's three factors in here and it
turns out that each of the factors are
necessary
so that there are examples you can come
up with where each of the factors are
needed the last Factor here the c k to
the N comes from the fact that maybe the
group G has a subgroup of size K times
little n
and then every subset of that subgroup
of size little n would be an a for which
a times a inverse would be at most K
times n because a a inverse would still
sit in that subgroup so you'd have KN
choose little n such subsets a and so
you'd have to get a factor that looks
like this from that another Factor you
get is something like n to the K here
and this n to the K Factor comes from if
you have a sub group of size little n
and then you add K arbitrary elements
you basically get n choices for each of
those arbitrary elements and the
doubling won't this differencing a a
inverse won't be that large the last uh
Factor big end the little log n comes up
if your group has lots of subgroups of a
given size so in the example of F2 to
the D you have lots of subgroups and
those subgroups will have small doubling
and so you get the big end to the log
Little M here so each of these factors
are needed and it turns out that as long
as you lose a constant here and product
them all it's an upper bound so these
are the sort of worst cases that can
happen
and it still looks like a question in
group Theory and these sorts of
questions what happens if you have small
doubling understanding
this type of condition is a really
fundamental problem in additive
combinatorics there's a famous theorem
of Fryman that tells you rough structure
of sets with with aan versus being small
and they look
if a is a subset of the integers it
looks like a box
um a projection of a box this is
fryman's theorem this was generalized by
uh green and Russia to General abelian
groups using the idea of coset
progressions and roulard uh green and
Tau later
had this fundamental work on approximate
subgroups which tells you a rough
structure in a non-abelian case
however those results are not strong
enough to get the types of results we
want here and we we're just asking for
counting bounds that say that there are
not many of these sets rather than tell
you what the structure of them are
and as I said earlier these this idea
that you would have a group operation
actually is uh is a red herring um
uh really what we should be doing uh is
changing it into a purely combinatorial
problem and the way we're going to do
this is we we think of a group G of
order n our favorite group maybe it's Z5
cyclic group on five elements
and we order the elements zero one two
three four
and then we're going to color the edges
based on what their uh their differences
um and so we're going to end up in this
example getting two color classes zero
one one two
two three three four
four zero and the other one
in terms of the color classes would be
uh this other five cycle zero two four
one three zero
um
and this Edge coloring of KN is such
that each color class is either one or
two regular in this example for Z5 each
of the color classes is too regular
um and another example if we are if we
like the group uh Z2 squared are written
additively
um
we have four elements zero zero zero one
one zero one one
and uh
we would get each color class forms a
perfect matching
so it's one regular
every vertex has degree one in this case
foreign
and then
um a Kaylee graph on G is this going to
be the edge Union of some of the color
classes so if we started off with a
cyclic group on five elements and we
pick none of the colors then we're going
to get an empty graph so if we pick one
of the colors the red color for example
we've got a five cycle turns out here
we'd also get a five cycle if we turn we
pick the other color and um and then if
we pick both colors we'd end up getting
the complete graph so what are the
Kaylee graphs on Z5 there's just three
of them the empty graph five cycle and
complete graph on five vertices
so uh now we have this combinatorial
picture and we can ignore that it came
from groups what are the properties that
are important here well each color class
is bounded degrees
and so we study this more General graph
model
consider an edge coloring C of a
complete graph an entangled graph is The
Edge Union of some of the color classes
why is it entangled well if two pairs
get the same color
they're either both together in our in
our graph or neither of them are so
they're entangled together
and uh we can Define the random
entangled graph GC of P that's formed by
including each color class with
probability P independently of each
other so for the random Kaylee graph
this would be we take the coloring that
comes from our group and then we take
say with P equals a half we we take each
color class with probability a half and
uh
what we can study here um it turns out
that the right condition to put on all
of this is just that each color class is
bounded degree and for Kaley graphs it
was uh maximum degree was at most two
for each color class so that comes
pretty easily
and the question is what can we say
about the uh
The Click number of random entangled
graphs if our coloring is Delta bounded
a very simple example of a Delta bounded
coloring is if C is Rainbow if all the
pairs of uh are different colors then we
would just be getting the air dish for
any random graphs of what we started
with in the beginning so this uh model
generalizes uh several well-known
classes of random graphs
and uh
um in terms of accounting result we
actually get the same exact counting
result from earlier without groups so
it's just about Edge colorings and then
um we're counting the number of subsets
of size little n that just see a few
colors inside and the same bound holds
um and so this generalizes the previous
result we mentioned
and uh also we get this uh
generalization of the the work on of the
result on random Kaylee graphs
um as long as it's Delta bounded The
Clique number is again going to be at
most log n Times log log n and so for
certain problems about Keeley graphs we
really should ignore the group structure
and try to just take something very
simple that some simple property that it
satisfies and this uh these bounded
degree uh these Delta bounded
entangled uh colorings is is how to go
about it
okay so
um
uh turning back to Shannon we were we
went off for a long time about Ramsay
Theory and uh we we are coming back now
to communication
um there's a beautiful work about
improved communication through
repetition about an improved in
communication through repetition
improved communication through
repetition
so uh
right so I'm going to introduce the
graph power G of n g to the n
and the power of a graph G has vertex
set which is the nth power of the vertex
set and two vertices which are n-tuples
of vertices from our original graph u
and v will be adjacent if they're
distinct and for each coordinate I
they're either equal in that coordinate
or they're adjacent in that coordinate
and um now why is this important well
um the independence number Alpha of G to
the N the size of the largest
independent set
is the maximum number of messages a
Channel with com with confusion graph G
can communicate without error in N uses
so if you want to send along a channel
messages that have possible confusions
this Independence number of the nth
power of uh of the confusion graph will
tell you how many messages you can you
can transmit without error
um and just let's see an explicit
example so we understand this
um if we look at the uh this graph on
five vertices and we send uh we're
allowed to send one uh a vertex and we
want to send a message uh as many
messages as possible without
uh uh without error if we send one of
our
um of our vertices well we could take
zero and two to start with and just send
one of those and there's no confusion
there
but if we say we're trying to set send 0
1 and 2 there would be confusion already
between zero and one and that's
problematic we'd like to transmit
information without error
so um so the maximum number of messages
with one use of this channel which has
this confusion graph that 0 and 1 can be
confused one and two two and three the
consecutive vertices along this cycle
can be confused that the maximum
possible number the messages we could
transmit through one one uses is two and
it's realized by for example the
independent set zero two what happens if
we're allowed to send uh two vertices
though so
um then we'd be looking at the
Independence number of the square of the
five cycle and one simple bound is just
to take an independent set of our graph
and then we can pick in the first
coordinate a Vertex from the Independent
set and the second coordinate another
vertex from the Independent set and we
would get up to four messages that we
could transmit through this but this
isn't optimal
um actually the independence number of
the square is going to be five and
there's a particular independent set you
can write down there are some others
uh and why are we getting five well this
is part of a more much more General
phenomenon the graph G here this is a
five cycle self-complementary if you
switch the edges and non-edges you would
end up with another five cycle so it's a
self-complementary graph it's isomorphic
to its complement
and you get in any self-complementary
graph the independence number of the
square of the graph is
um is at least the number of vertices
and the reason why is you can write down
a large independent set which consists
of the pairs X comma Pi of X where Pi is
the isomorphism from G to its complement
and this is going to form an independent
set in G squared and the reason for this
is suppose you had two of these uh
vertices in G squared x Pi of X and Y Pi
of Y
If X and Y are adjacent so that's the
first coordinates adjacent then Pi of x
Pi Y is going to be not adjacent and so
that those two vertices won't be an edge
and they're going to uh so
they'll end up in this independent set
great okay so there's a fairly large uh
independent set in the square of a
self-complementary graph
um
now getting back to so Shannon's uh
viewing errorless communication
um
if the right way to normalize this is to
take the nth power of the confusion
graph G and take the independence number
of that and then take that to the 1 over
n power and this is the maximum number
of messages per use of the channel
in N uses
um
and uh so uh the Shannon capacity of the
channel is the this limiting uh uh cnfg
as n goes to Infinity is the shadow
capacity and it's an important graph
parameter which uh
um recoding Theory and yet we really
understand very little little about this
so for the five cycle we saw earlier
that construction we gave earlier gives
cfgs at least square root of five from
that and
um
and it's that's actually tight so it's
equal to the for the five cycle it's
it's square root of five
um that's roughly all we know so we
don't know the seven cycle and there's
many other things we don't know about
the Shannon capacity of graphs
um in particular uh
if you take a random graph on on Big N
vertices what is the Shannon capacity
look like well we know it's at least the
independence number of a random graph
so it's going to be at least something
logarithmic in the number of vertices
and we also know from other techniques
that it's at most square root of the
number of vertices so we have this
gigantic gap between log n and square
root of N and people have studied this
and haven't really been able to improve
on this at all so um it shows how little
we understand this important graph
parameter
um
uh in the mid 90s alone and orlitsky
proved that there are self-complementary
Ramsey graphs and why is this uh helpful
well because it's a Ramsey graph see one
of G is going to be the independence
number of the because the independence
number is only logarithmic of the number
of vertices C1 of G will end up being on
the order of log of the number of
vertices of the confusion graph and yet
if you are allowed to transmit to twice
over the channel you've got a huge
Improvement in in communication for such
channels because
um the number of messages per use jumps
from logarithmic to square root of the
number of vertices you've got this
gigantic Improvement
and uh so uh so
um it connects up at these important uh
Concepts that came back from the late
40s uh that erdish and uh Shannon were
studying
uh Alana olitzki made the following
stronger conjecture and it would give an
analogous result for the whiten housing
rate for dual Source coding and instead
of looking at the Independence number of
graph Powers this Whitson housing rate
is related to the chromatic number of
the graph powers
and they conjectured that there exists
self-complementary Ramsay Kaylee graphs
so they prove that there are
self-complementary
Ramsey graphs and we already knew that
there were that there are Ramsay Kaylee
grass but we like both all of these
properties at once
and uh so we proved this conjecture
um and uh one of the ideas here is to go
beyond uniform random so instead of
taking a random graph Achilles graph by
taking every element uniformly at random
which doesn't work in the setting we're
going to look at
so we're gonna have
we're going to have n be 5 to the D and
we're going to look at a uniform random
symmetric subset of F5 to the D Vector
space over F5 of Dimension d
it has big on vertices uh we're gonna
make a Kaylee graph which has begun
vertices and asymptotically almost
surely just like for F2 this will
contain uh the non-zero elements of a
Subspace of order on the log n Times log
log n and hence the Kaley graph we get
this random Kaley graph well
asymptotically almost surely contains a
clique that that that's that big so it's
not going to be a if we took a random
uniform random subset over F5 to the D
it's not going to be a Ramsay Kaylee
graph so we're going to come up with
something that's a variant of this and
and actually drop from log n log log n
down to log n
um and so that we're going to prove that
there are self-complementary Ramsay
Kaylee graphs on that 5 for the D
and uh the main tool is this counting
result from earlier that I mentioned
about Delta bounded Edge colorings
um and from this counting result and a
little bit of additional lemmas it's uh
not too difficult to show that it
suffices
to pick a random self-complementary
Kaylee graph on F5 to the D in which
each possible Clique a has a minus a
this is the same thing as this a a
inverse we saw earlier but because the
groups of billion we write uh instead of
addition instead of products we have
addition here so a minus a the different
set
um that it grows that it's at least a
Times log a and the reason for this is
precisely you see this K plus log n
you'd like to log n to be smaller than
the K here and that's where this log is
coming from so we'd like some growth on
different sets for for possible cliques
and we'd like it to behave somewhat like
a uh as before that if we have our set a
and we want to look at the probability
that it's a click that's at most
exponentially small in the size of uh a
minor of the set a minus a so once we
have those properties and the
construction we're going to come up with
will easily have the second property and
the first property is a more interesting
one for this example that we're going to
give in a minute which is that the a
minus a for any possible clique
will have to be large
so here's the construction
for each non-zero element of our uh
Vector space over F5 we're going to
randomly pick exactly one of X and 4x
this pair and 2X and 3X so there's these
two pairs these are inverses of each
other 4X is negative of X and 3X is
negative of 2x so if x is in our
generating set 4X will also have to be
in our generating set and um so uh the
line containing X will have four
non-zero elements and we'll pick exactly
two of them to end up in our generating
set for every such element X and we're
going to do this for every one of these
lines and by doing this this guarantees
that our set s is symmetric our
generating set
and our uh Kaley graph we've picked a
random clearly graph is
self-complementary with a simple
isomorphism that we send X to 2X
and then the third property that comes
from this is that uh if x is in our
generating set then 2x is not in our
generating set
um and the third property uh implies
that if a is going to be a click in our
random daily graph then a plus 2 times a
this is the dilation of a by two so we
multiply every element of a by two and
this is the sum set so we're looking at
the set of elements of the form a plus
2B where little a and little B are
elements of a and this last property
implies that all those sums a plus 2B
they're all going to be distinct and so
we're going to a squared of them
um and uh we got this uh simple line of
inequalities the first one was just what
we said this equality the second one uh
is is Trivial a plus two times a is a
subset of a plus a plus a this is the
sumset which consists of the elements uh
little a plus little B plus little C
which are elements of our set a and this
last uh inequality here is an
application of the punicarusia
inequality and this is one of the
fundamental inequalities in additive
combinatorics and when we put this
together it yields that a minus a the
size of it it's going to have to be at
least a to the fourth thirds and all we
needed to get was a Times log a and this
grows bigger than that and you can also
very easily check this probabilistic
condition that we wanted as well so this
is the uh this is the proof and um
uh
right so are there any questions about
any of this so far
um great so I'm gonna just talk for a
quick bit about General random graph
models so we've talked about a few
random graph models already we talked
about the Irish running random graph
where we pick every Edge to be an edge
of our graph independently of the other
possible edges uh with the same
probability we looked at random Kaley
graphs we looked at these random and
tingled graphs
um and they all satisfy a more general
setting
um and there's other random graph models
that people have studied and it seems
that a good notion to study is this
Delta independent random graphs suppose
we have a random graph G and it has the
property that for each pair of vertices
e it appears as an edge of our graph
with probability some P sub B and
appears independently of all edges apart
from those in in a graph G sub e
um and we say that g is Delta
independent this random graph is Delta
independent if the maximum degree of
this dependency graph GE is bounded by
at most Delta for each pair e and for
those who are familiar with the Lobos
local Lemma this looks a lot like the
condition from the Lobos local Lemma you
have bad events in the low boss local
Emma and each bad event appears
independently of all but a bounded
number of other bad events this is a
weaker condition where we you actually
can have lots of other dependencies but
they form a bounded degree grass so this
is a weaker condition and it's the right
sort of condition from the the models we
were studying earlier and um there are
these different models people have
studied and asked questions about uh
Kelly graphs and click numbers and
Independence numbers and things along
those lines and under this general
setting you can prove a general bounds
one thing you can't uh improve on erdish
Reni uh Bound for for Ramsay numbers
with any random graph from this model
so uh that's what the first results
telling you as long as Delta is not too
large
The Click number
um
of such a random uh a Delta independent
random graph will be at least what you
get in the air dish ready random graph
asymptotically
um and in the other direction our
results generalized to get this big O
log n log log n Bound for these Delta
independent random graph models but here
we have a stronger condition on Delta
that it's at most to constant
okay
um so and we'll finish with some open
problems that I think are really quite
interesting we mentioned already this
conjecture of noga alone that there's a
constant C such that every finite group
has a Kaley graph which is C Ramsey
and uh an important step in this
direction I think if one solves this
there's a decent chance one would be
able to really make good progress and
maybe solve the whole conjecture
um I think this is really the hard part
of it even though this sounds a lot
easier
um and what this is asking for is just
that there's a two coloring of the
non-zero elements of the vector space
over F2
um
of Dimension D such that there's no
Subspace of size constant times D whose
non-zero zero elements are monochromatic
so um
that's what it's asking for if you take
a uniformly random two coloring of F2 to
the D
it would give you D Times log D and this
is corresponding to the log n Times log
log n we saw earlier where n is 2 to the
D
um and so we'd like to do something
better than uniform random here and we
we don't know how there are some lower
bounds on this problem that are much
smaller than this so it may be that c
times D is just really wrong lower
bounds are some finite number of
iterated logarithms which follows from
work of Tom Sanders
on bounds on rotto numbers
uh
right okay so I'll finish here thank you
[Applause]
yeah so uh do you get any results for
this first random killing that setting
uh say on density of uh small subclass
It's a Wonderful fashion we've tried so
far and haven't been able to make
progress on that so it's a hard question
and
um in our counting results we were
counting subsets okay
um what you'd like to do is
approximately count different sets and
so you you don't want to count all the
whole different set but much of a
different set and there's not really
good techniques for that right now yeah
so
one could do this there would be lots of
nice conversations and number Theory and
for um
but uh yeah so the sparse setting uh is
a great problem
sure seems really similar to these
objects
with your balance
mm-hmm
well so so Random Works uh
um so you need something that beats
uniformly random
um and so a random would only get you to
subspaces of size d Times log B in terms
of the dimension it would be log B plus
log log d
is not a Dimensions the size okay yeah
right so it's it's a it's a little bit
uh yeah fine here are there any
candidates sure I don't know of any I'd
be it would be great if someone has some
interesting ideas for that I think I
teach random
Ness
[Music]
this question is asking for the layers
of this is not the iPhone yeah
so you had this upper bound that
appeared a couple of times but based on
like three factors each one individually
is needed is it known if a combinations
are neither if you could just take like
a Max of each of the three
well we put a constant C in the exponent
at least for the first term and it's a
great question about what the actual
sort of fine asymptotics are and people
have been trying to study these as
special cases of groups
um we had this exponent of c times K
plus log of little n it was n to this
this thing
um if you can replace C by one in
certain instances it tells you a lot so
in front of the K if you replace C by
one
um it'll tell you that you're really
matching erditerranean you can do that
in some general settings if you can
replace the C in front of the log n by
one and we can but then we don't have a
good dependence on K it grows with K
more than linear then you get a
combinatorial extension of Simon's
theorem over F2 and so there's a
combinatorial prime in Russia theorem
that comes from this
but it's a great question and it's going
to depend uh
in General on the group structure it
seems so um if you look at random Theory
graphs but
um yeah so we don't have the fine
asymptotics
so you have the services
unless they have too many factors of two
or three in there in that order is that
saying that you can construct the two
coloring in a lot of groups
yes I see explicitly sometimes yes so we
did this in this F5 and that generalizes
[Applause]
foreign